bonjour tout le monde alors avouons-le notre
activité numérique n'a jamais été aussi
intense ça va vite et nous continuerons à le
faire si nous ne changeons pas ses
comportements et nous devons le faire car cette
activité en ligne massive entraîne une
empreinte désastreuse
sachant que la navigation sans but  sur
Facebook ou regarder d'innombrables heures de
Game of Thrones sur OCS n'est pas aussi
innocent que cela puisse paraître comment pouvons-nous adopter
des pratiques numériques sobres pour discuter avec notre
capacité à réduire l'impact physique du
numérique veuillez accueillir John Lobb sur le
catalyseur de réinitialisation à l'Open Compute
Projet et jean-marc
jancovici président du projet shift
bienvenue donc premier départ en tant que marque John
pourriez-vous nous en dire un peu plus sur ce que
vous faites avec le projet shift et
le projet Open Compute et qui était-
ce qu'est-ce qu'un catalyseur de réinitialisation  commençons
par votre John
bien merci beaucoup d'être venu
et d'avoir écouté je suis vraiment surpris par
la taille de l'auditoire juste une question
combien d'entre vous sont au courant  l'Open
Compute Project 3 plutôt bien c'est des
gens libres c'est bien c'est
assez intéressant il y a une
entreprise française qui est l'une des
entreprises à la croissance la plus rapide en France elle est très
fortement impliquée l'année dernière, elle
employait environ 13 personnes et
vendait 1 000 ordinateurs par  semaine,
il y a donc de bonnes opportunités dans ce domaine
ainsi que dans la réduction des émissions de carbone, mais mon rôle
est de parler aux gens et d'
essayer d'encourager l'adoption de
matériel open source pour les
centres informatiques, donc si vous utilisez des applications comme les gens
utilisent Facebook dans cette pièce  Les
utilisateurs de Facebook s'aperçoivent que tout
fonctionne sur des logiciels et du matériel open source,
toute l'infrastructure Microsoft fonctionne
sur du matériel open source, c'est ce
que je fais.  en termes
de réduction de carbone, un ordinateur Open Compute
utilisera environ 50 % moins d'
énergie qu'un ordinateur propriétaire traditionnel
s  o c'est moi
qu'est-ce que tu fais ce projet de merde est une
douleur dans le cou nous essayons d'encourager le
passage de l'économie actuelle à une économie à
faible émission de carbone, donc nous sommes une
entreprise et une géo d'un certain type
essayant de défendre notre meilleure
négociation  maintenant est de décarboner l'économie
c'est essentiellement ce que nous faisons d'accord
c'était rapide alors vous avez posé la question ouais
vous y avez répondu nous avons vu que la
part du numérique dans les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre a été réduite de moitié depuis 2013,
passant de deux virgule cinq pour cent à  trois
virgule sept pour cent des
émissions mondiales totales, mais avec un certain contexte et une certaine
échelle ici, donc quelle est l'autre source,
c'est que bien polluer, la première chose
est que pour savoir s'il est
ennuyeux de savoir si les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre augmentent, je pense que j'ai  quelques
diapositives, ils peuvent apparaître c'est tout, nous
devons savoir exactement où nous devons aller en
ce qui concerne les émissions de gaz à effet de serre,
donc c'est un graphique qui est tiré du
dernier rapport du GIEC y a-t-il plus que
trois personnes dans la salle qui ont entendu
parler du GIEC oui d'accord ce n'est pas si
nombreux donc le graphique ici dit que la
réponse du système climatique aux
émissions accumulées est linéaire donc
fondamentalement vous regardez sur l'
axe horizontal vers le haut les
émissions accumulées de l'humanité et  vous obtenez sur l'
axe vertical l'augmentation de température
que nous aurons en 2100 par rapport à l'
époque préindustrielle c'est très
simple fin 2017 d'accord
nous avions admis que beaucoup c'est 2200
milliards de tonnes de co2 et donc nous nous sommes
déjà engagés à 1,5  degrés de
réchauffement climatique qui arriveront au
plus tard en 2100 si on arrête d'émettre pour
pousser en gémissant et bien sûr si on n'arrête pas
une réunion demain matin on les
aura plus tôt mais je veux dire le 1.5 est
déjà embarqué dans les émissions passées
car il faut attendre 10 000 ans que le
co2 arrive de l'atmosphère pour se
débarrasser d'un surplus de co2 10 000 ans d'
accord si on veut l'objectif de 2 degrés
qu'il faut limiter à 8 les émissions
accumulées  ons à 3000 milliards de tonnes de co2
dont bien sûr 2200 j'ai déjà été
émis ça veut dire qu'il reste 800 c'est
un tiers de ce qu'on a déjà émis
avec l'humanité qui est en
gros trois fois plus nombreuse d'accord
c'est le challenge qui est  le
défi des deux degrés signifie essentiellement
que les émissions de co2 doivent être divisées par
trois dans le monde au moment où les plus
jeunes dans cette pièce auront mon âge d'accord
au moment où mes enfants ne riront pas parce que vous
pourriez avoir l'âge de mes enfants si presque
au moment où vous avez mon âge, ils devraient être
divisés par trois à ces deux
degrés d'accord, alors maintenant la question est de savoir si le
numérique est compatible avec cela, donc nous
pensons tous que le numérique est dématérialisé d'
accord, mais juste pour que le système numérique
fonctionne, nous avons besoin d'esprits qui  ne sont pas
dématérialisés on a fait de la métallurgie qui
n'est pas dématérialisée il faut des
industries pétrolières et des industries chimiques qui
ne sont pas D matérialisées
il faut des industries verrières qui ne sont pas D
matérialisées il faut de l'extra pur  nous avons besoin d'eau nous avons
besoin d'assemblage nous avons besoin de travaux publics
parce que nous avons besoin d'usines et nous avons besoin de
transport nous avons besoin de
moyens de transport bien sûr nous avons même besoin de lancer des
satellites avec des fusées et nous devons
alimenter le tout et 40% de l'
électricité sur terre vient du
charbon  les usines et les centrales au charbon
représentent à elles seules 20% des émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre d'accord
donc le résultat c'est que quand tu
fabriques un ordinateur tu as émis
une demi tonne de co2 dans l'atmosphère
donc tu penses que ça se dématérialise parce que
quand tu avais ton ordinateur sur ton  les genoux
n'émettent pas de fumée ça ne sent pas
ou ça ne devrait pas du moins et donc vous
pensez que c'est parfaitement propre mais le
fait est qu'il n'est pas propre parce que vous
avez dû le fabriquer et si vous regardez
les émissions globales  du système numérique
qui gère réellement le centre de données
ne représente que vingt-vingt pour cent du
problème et en passant, vous ne triez pas les
électrons dans la prise du
centre de données, alors achetez de l'énergie propre  gy baby, nous
discuterons plus tard que la perspicacité est en
fait une illusion
vous n'achetez pas d'électricité propre vous achetez
ce qui vient du réseau c'est tout et
vous voyez que la fabrication de l'appareil représente
environ la moitié de l'empreinte carbone du
système mondial maintenant avec  le temps c'est l'
une des capacités Patek de l'informatique dans de
nombreux secteurs industriels il arrive
qu'avec le temps les choses s'améliorent par exemple dans
les industries manufacturières à l'échelle mondiale vous avez
besoin d'un peu moins d'énergie aujourd'hui
qu'hier par exemple pour écraser un morceau
d'acier il arrive que dans l'informatique
secteur il évolue en sens inverse le
contenu carbone d'un appareil aujourd'hui est
supérieur à ce qu'il était il y a un an ou deux
ans ou trois ans le
contenu carbone d'un dollar de valeur ajoutée dans
le système informatique dans l'industrie informatique
est supérieur aujourd'hui  est plus grand aujourd'hui
qu'il y a quelques années, il
augmente avec le temps ok et ici vous
avez l'exemple par exemple d'un
appareil Apple, donc l'
empreinte carbone du système informatique  em le
système numérique mondial représentait 2,5% des
émissions mondiales il y a quelques années,
ce qui équivaut aux émissions de la flotte aérienne
de l'aviation mondiale ok aujourd'hui,
c'est l'équivalent de la flotte de camions dans
le monde
4% et dans quelques années dans un
comme d'habitude, cela va être
équivalent au parc automobile dans le monde,
donc il augmente de 10% par an,
alors qu'il devrait diminuer en
chiffres absolus de 4% par an afin
d'être compatible avec l'
objectif de deux degrés,
donc fondamentalement, il y a un  15 pour cent par
an d'écart entre ce qu'il faudrait faire pour que
l'informatique soit vraiment une
industrie dématérialisée et ce qui se passe réellement
ici vous avez les émissions mondiales de gaz à effet de
serre de GES depuis un siècle et
demi l'industrie numérique a commencé
là évidemment vous n'avez pas  voyez un changement par
rapport à la tendance en fait, ce que vous voyez est
une accélération du taux d'augmentation
et pas du tout une diminution des émissions mondiales,
donc l'idée qu'il y a
tech4good que je  s que globalement l'
industrie numérique se porte bien dans le
reste du monde n'est pas vrai car
sinon vous devriez voir quelque chose sur
cette courbe vous devriez voir un ralentissement
du taux de croissance alors que vous voyez
exactement l'inverse qui dure dans un
ordinateur vous en avez quarante  à soixante métaux
différents métaux la plupart d'entre eux ne sont pas
recyclés et ne le seront pas parce qu'ils
sont présents à la concentration qui
est beaucoup beaucoup plus petite beaucoup trop petite
désolé pour que vous puissiez recycler ce qui est
inclus dans un ordinateur donc essentiellement
recycler un ordinateur revient
cuivre or argent étain et c'est tout le
reste vous n'avez pas donc ce que vous avez avec l'
appareil que vous achetez c'est que vous avez une
durée de vie de 18 mois en moyenne entre
ce que vous avez à gauche et ce que vous
avez à droite d'accord donc dedans  un mot
pas durable du tout d'accord donc ce n'est
pas durable mais on peut agir sur les 19
% que sont les datacenters on
a diverses sources de pollution et
divers éléments qui polluent  g mais
concentrons-nous sur les centres de données ou les
centres informatiques comme vous les appelez John, que pouvons-
nous réduire en les rendant plus verts et et
comment les rendez-vous plus verts bien d'
abord, je suis tout à fait d'accord avec cet
homme sur ce qu'il a dit et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je  Je me suis donné son titre de
catalyseur de réinitialisation parce que
le problème difficile est de changer
l'état d'esprit intuitif des gens, laissez-moi
vous donner un exemple. Je vais parler à beaucoup de
grandes banques et j'essaie de les encourager
à utiliser ce genre de
solutions à faible consommation d'énergie et je l'ai fait  un atelier
pour l'une des plus grandes banques britanniques c'est une
énorme banque et ils ont fait un calcul et
ils ont calculé qu'ils économiseraient 20
millions de livres par an sur la
facture d'électricité plus toute la réduction de carbone
s'ils adoptaient simplement ces technologies open source
sans vanité  que l'hyper
échelle est utilisée mais l'ont-ils fait non ils
ne l'ont pas fait parce qu'il y a une autre
conséquence qui est liée à tout cela avec
ces nouveaux types de j'ai même un nouveau mot
pour ça je ne le fais pas  n'utilisez plus le mot perturbateur
J'ai utilisé le mot romper ceci
parce que les technologies open source sont
plus que perturbatrices, une conséquence de l'
adoption de ces technologies par cette grande banque
est qu'elle allait
réduire considérablement ses effectifs d'
environ 80% maintenant que le directeur de l'
information aurait perdu son
donc il y a beaucoup de types de doigts auxquels
vous devez penser tout le
temps mais je suis très très motivé pour apporter des
changements et donnons quelques exemples
de certains des changements que les logiciels open source
ont apportés si vous exécutez open
logiciel source sur du matériel informatique traditionnel
, vous pouvez facilement réduire de 80% la quantité de
matériel physique dont vous avez réellement besoin,
car sur un
serveur ou un ordinateur typique, vous n'exécutez
qu'une utilisation moyenne généralement dans une
entreprise, une grande banque ou les gouvernements d'un
gouvernement du  pire, vous pourriez
envisager une utilisation moyenne de
moins de 10% maintenant, quel logiciel open source
fait-il mettre plus de charge de travail sur un
seul  la machine augmente cette utilisation
et donc vous obtenez une utilisation plus efficace
du matériel et vous pouvez éradiquer dans la
plupart des entreprises et je peux garantir pour
tous les centres de données de l'Union européenne que vous
pouvez éradiquer 80% de tout le matériel
maintenant un dernier point cette petite
entreprise française  qui vend des milliers d'
ordinateurs chaque semaine ou quand ils
ont été achetés, ils ont dit qu'il y en avait beaucoup plus maintenant que
tous ces ordinateurs étaient des ordinateurs réutilisés à
partir de centres de données à grande échelle,
aucun d'entre eux n'était nouveau parce que si nous
allons traiter tout le carbone incarné que
nous avons  pour continuer à utiliser ce truc et combien
de personnes sont au courant de ce
qui se passe que ces ordinateurs hyperscale
sont utilisés dans de grandes entreprises il y a une
très grande entreprise à Paris dont tout le monde a
entendu parler assez oh ils utilisent ce truc
et ils en utilisent des dégâts donc les Français
sont  en tête, mais le problème que nous
avons en open source, nous n'avons pas de gros
budgets marketing, je ne suis pas un IBM qui
peut dépenser une fortune en marketing, c'est
juste l  je me moque de moi et j'essaie d'amener des
passionnés et des champions à
nous aider à commercialiser si nous changeons la perspective
dans votre dernier rapport John Mark, vous avez
parlé de la sobriété numérique, qu'est-ce que c'est
et comment pouvons-nous y parvenir en tant qu'individu,
il s'agit essentiellement d'examiner ce qui a été
fait  a dit que c'est acheter comme légal la
plus petite quantité possible d'appareil et le
garder aussi longtemps que possible en
gros c'est de la sobriété numérique donc
ça n'augmente pas le nombre d'
objets qui sont connectés ça
n'augmente pas ça ne passe pas de quatre g25
G à 6 GE - je  je ne sais pas - 3 PG quoi
qu'il en soit, cela n'augmente pas la taille des écrans
tout le temps, c'est donc essentiellement
essayer de partir
heureux pour toujours avec ce que nous avons déjà
et diminuer la taille du
matériel que nous utilisons essentiellement mais les
gens sont-ils prêts  pour le faire, je ne suis pas
sûr que les gens soient prêts à se retrouver dans une
vache généralisée vers laquelle nous nous dirigeons
avec tous les problèmes environnementaux que
nous avons si fondamentalement pour ma  ke un
choix il faut connaître les termes du
choix aujourd'hui les gens connaissent le terme du
choix à court terme d'une part je
vais avoir mon écran dans le métro
bien mais ils ne connaissent généralement pas l'
alternative qui est cela va
avec le fait qu'on va avoir
une facture très élevée à payer sans avoir les
moyens de la payer c'est ça le problème pour
qu'il y ait un gros disome' try entre
ce que les gens savent concernant la tech et ce
qu'ils veulent savoir concernant les
problèmes environnementaux et concernant le
budget marketing d'IBM ou d'autres, ce que je peux voir,
c'est que les gens de l'industrie de la technologie
ne sont pas vraiment désireux de financer des initiatives
pour que les gens sachent vraiment ce qui va
se passer avec le changement climatique financent
plein de choses mais pas ça mais mais on
voit que la connaissance  éclate et
et ce sujet est de plus en plus couvert
par les médias et tout ça il y a une
différence entre parler beaucoup de
quelque chose et bien parler ou quelque chose
puis-je juste ajouter quelques points
parce que c'est un gros problème complexe le
changement climatique dans la décarbonisation
du réseau le réseau intelligent en termes
d'informatique les réseaux d'énergie la plus grande
machine que l'homme ait jamais faite c'est
Internet l'Internet est un projet open source
le plus grand puzzle que l'homme ait
jamais résolu  est le projet de génome qui a
été réalisé de manière ouverte lors du
développement de ces technologies pour
résoudre ce problème, toutes les informations
que chaque chercheur a recueillies ont été mises
sur Internet dans le domaine public
afin que tout le monde puisse en
bénéficier, vous avez donc obtenu de cette position où si
vous  regardez en arrière vers 2001, le coût pour
cartographier un génome humain était de cent millions de
dollars aujourd'hui, c'est moins de mille
et ce qui se cache derrière, ce sont les communautés open source
qui ont rendu cela possible
maintenant si nous voulons sauver le
changement climatique, nous en avons besoin  sorte de communauté pour
y arriver et c'est vraiment assez
dégoûtant que les centres informatiques ne
définissent même pas ce que leurs
structures de rapport libre de portée  sont presque sans portée,
c'est tout ce carbone incarné, ils ne font même pas de
rapport directement, ils commencent à le
faire et nous recevons peut-être un peu de
législation qui forcera peut-être
que nous commencerons à voir un changement maintenant,
vous ne le savez peut-être pas  ceci, mais en mars de l'
année prochaine, il y aura une nouvelle législation européenne sur
l'efficacité énergétique des
serveurs informatiques dans les centres de données, donc c'est une bonne
décision, d'accord, nous n'avons plus de temps,
malheureusement, si vous aviez un dernier conseil
pour notre public, que serions-
nous au sujet de quoi  des pratiques très numériques
ouais dont je dirais juste
que c'est un sujet sérieux pas John pas
juste un gadget c'est un sujet sérieux
et quand je viens m'asseoir dans ce genre de
conférences et parler aux gens je
veux juste laisser les gens avec juste une nouvelle
chose  dans leur tête quand je pars pourriez-
vous juste m'aider
avez-vous appris une nouvelle chose aujourd'hui
qui pourrait être utile pour l'avenir
quelqu'un cela en valait la peine merci
beaucoup pour votre temps